welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and the she-hulk series sees the past
finally catch up with the incredible
hulk when the grand master's courier
shift came to crash the party along with
the hulk family minivan leading to
jennifer walters becoming the savage
she-hulk and forcing bruce banner to
pull a master theft auto in order to
take a quick trip back to sakaar to
quote take care of some stuff in the
most vague way possible at least i think
he's heading back to sakaar because it's
a courier craft but what if the grand
master wasn't the only part of mcu hulk
history to come back with a vengeance
how would you feel if i told you that
bruce banner's biggest and baddest
villain yet could and frankly should
come in the form of one edward norton
the incredible 2008 hulk himself well
now that king the conqueror has set the
mcu gps on the road to multiverse mayhem
that road now has the amazing potential
to give us an mcu match-up that we have
only dreamed of witnessing let's talk
about him and nerd babies but first head
on over to new rockstarsmerch.com so you
can pick up our latest obsession shirts
inspired by house of the dragon it's
freaking game of thrones time everybody
you can find that shirt or any of all of
our incredible gear over at
newrockstarsmerch.com all right gang
here's the deal you want world war hulk
i want world war hawk and even mark
ruffalo wants world war hulk the world
demands a hulk war damage i think now is
the perfect time for marvel studios to
reach out to one edward norton to return
as the incredible hulk not to replace
mark ruffalo god no but given that phase
5 is going full-on multiverse with
projects like secret wars loki season 2
what if and quantomania marvel studios
has clearly only begun to introduce the
concept of variance to everybody's
eyeballs and kang basically promised a
chaotic multiverse with variants flying
all over the place starting wars right
before sylvie opened up his chest cavity
with vengeance so i cannot imagine a
more fruitful opportunity for marvel
studios to green light a world war hulk
project with none other than edward
norton as the biggest threat to the mcu
since thanos listen guys while i'm
focused on work some things in my life
fall by the wayside like brushing my
teeth doing my laundry showering now
that i say it out loud it's mostly
hygiene my god i should probably take
care of myself better
what a bad luck but with gaming i can
keep up thanks to mobile legends
adventure it's an idol rpg so while i'm
working to find easter eggs my squad is
leveling up thanks squad
you're a real one squad in mobile
legends adventure you can customize your
adventure squad and each squad has five
heroes and each hero comes from one of
seven factions and each hero has unique
abilities like the most popular
elemental hero velir who's able to knock
enemies back and deal massive damage and
with multiple game modes and over 100
heroes to choose from mobile legends
adventure never gets repetitive and of
all the heroes alice is my personal
favorite because she's like loki like a
smart and sneaky warlock who generates
hp by attacking enemies and the game
also has a great character-driven
storyline so as you complete more stages
and add more heroes to your collection
you'll get to know more about each
hero's story tigreel and alucard were
close like brothers until they were
driven apart by a family tragedy like
thor and loki i love those parallels and
for summer there's a special island
party event going on during which you
can complete tasks to gain tons of
rewards and you can also get special
summer skins for freyja selena wanman
and mobile legends adventures newest
hero tokinibara participate in the event
now and use the gift code on screen to
get tons of awesome rewards and click
the link in the description for a chance
to get a ps5 switch or amazon gift card
i'll see you there my friends adventure
awaits anytime anywhere downloaded now
mobile legends adventure all right thor
ragnarok as beloved as that movie is
definitely provided a much lighter take
on the hulk's time on sakhar than his
comic book counterpart had because that
comic book hulk was having considerably
less fun of a time alongside much more
gruesome versions of korg and meek in an
angry army of armageddon known as the
war battle an army that would of course
have an intense blood thirst for revenge
against earth after hulk blames humanity
for the destruction of everything and
everyone he loved on sequoia like this
army was no joke and practically almost
succeeded in destroying the entire
planet let's be real as much as we truly
adore oregon meek in the mcu if you told
me that core was going to help hulk turn
the pentagon into pebbles i would laugh
in your face i would i would just be
like
that's what i would say and zero
disrespect to our favorite radical rock
man because i too am a pacifist by
nature but dude couldn't even handle new
master 69 without praying to god for
help but the beauty about now being on
the road to secret wars is that the mcu
can now make this happen courtesy of
sylvian kang wrecking the timeline in
the loki season finale especially since
marvel has now confirmed that the
universe hopping adventures of both
spider-man no way home and doctor
strange the multiverse of madness could
not have happened without the sacred
timeline branching and intersecting out
of control an event that also probably
likely led to the interdimensional
clandestines being able to come into the
616 universe from their universe via an
energy rift in space time no way home
style this means that marvel studios now
has set themselves up with the
opportunity to have edward norton
continue his own incredible hulk story
in a new and unique way of becoming the
next nano size threat to the mcu-616 by
having norton hulk gather his own
war-bound army from his universe to seek
revenge on his earth but accidentally
going through one of those weird new
rifts in spacetime and finding his way
to mark ruffalo's earth instead and
because norton's hulk would likely be
just as bloodthirsty as the comic book
hulk was in world war hulk like this
dude is probably not going to care that
he is on the completely wrong earth he
just wants to see people die not only
would this be a phenomenal phase 5
multiverse move and the greatest
challenge for mark ruffalo's hulk yet
but doing something like this is also
extremely fitting considering hulk's
journey so far and especially
considering what hulk said to his cousin
jenny from the block in episode 1 of
she-hulk when people start seeing you as
a monster that never goes away mark
ruffalo's hulk has spent so many years
trying to convince the world that he is
not the monster that everyone thinks he
is after raging on a college campus
destroying the cities of harlem in
johannesburg and smashing up a shield
helicarry it was his main concern that's
why his binder is so [ __ ] big and his
alter ego hulk's main concern is being
the strongest hulk that there is which
is something that we can already tell
he's pissed about now that she-hulk is
out here smashing too if another variant
hulk showed up on earth claiming himself
to be the real hulk and the strongest
one that there is both mark ruffalo's
bruce banner and the hulk persona are
going to be extremely pissed off for
their own reasons bruce is pissed off
that his name is being dragged in the
mud and hulk is pissed off that he's no
longer the strongest hulk and his
strength is being challenged potentially
leading us into seeing a side of mark
ruffalo's hulk that we have yet to see
to stop norton hulk and his army from
destroying everything and ruining
bruce's good name plus smart hulk is not
the end game for bruce banner in the mcu
it should be obvious i feel like that's
obvious but i feel like a lot of people
don't think that's obvious because the
hulk transformation is closely linked to
anger and emotion in general it is truly
only a matter of time until mark
ruffalo's wild avengers 1 and 2 hulk
comes back in full form bigger and
badder than ever and i cannot think of a
better reason for that to happen than
for the world to have to endure the
absolute devastation that having both of
the mcu's bruce banners go head to head
in a world war hulk movie it would truly
be world war hulk because two hulks
would be at it like do you know how many
tickets that would sell marvel you gotta
do it literally you got to do it like
the multiverse has cracked wide open and
anything is possible and hulk fans
everywhere have been comparing the
ferocity of both ruffalo and norton's
hulks for years i say it's time to end
the debate once and for all and show us
which of these two hulks would win in a
live-action world war hulk scenario and
hey if you're looking for a post-credits
scene idea and uh you know 2003 eric
banda hulk isn't doing anything the mcu
multiverse still very much needs a
maestro just saying it would be quite
perfect and uh eric banner you miss him
put him in the mcu too let's have a hulk
party let's do spiderman no way hulk no
pulker man no way hulk there we go
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you guys
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but
most importantly you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media also importantly head on over to
new rockstarsmerch.com today you can
pick up our new latest obsession shirts
inspired by both she-hulk and house of
the dragon i'll see you guys next time
bye
[Music]
you